Hi everyone.
Um,
I'm Rachel and welcome to the latest installation of talks at Google.
I'm happy to announce my personal friend and colleague,
Peter Benjamin.
I met Peter about four years ago.
He was recommended to me by someone who's built an acrobat and a Thai massage
practitioner.
And her words were,
if you're serious about fixing that hamstring,
here's the person to go to.
And I looked up this guy,
Peter Benjamin,
two first names,
what's up,
right?
He was a long way away from me.
It took me about an hour of taking a really inconvenient and bus and then walk
in halfway across Watertown to get to see this crazy person.
And I was like,
this person better be a wizard or else I have never taken this trip again.
And one hour later I said,
I'll be back next Tuesday.
And the one after that and the one after that,
because he had not only figured out what was wrong with my hamstring,
but the reason why I kept injuring it over and over again.
No,
I have my rights.
Let's again.
So thank you Peter,
and I am very pleased to welcome you to Google.
[inaudible].
Thank you Rachel and thank you for bringing me here.
So I want to,
there's a lot that I want to get to today.
Talk a little bit about injuries,
pain healing and some of the things that get in the way of that.
Um,
but before I do that,
I'm just going to tell you a little bit about me and how I got to where I am.
And to do that,
we need to go back a generation.
So,
um,
when my father was 13 years old,
he was training to be a professional dancer and he got a serious low back injury
and um,
his mother took him to the physician and they recommended surgery and she said,
what's wrong with him?
And they said,
well,
we don't know,
but we'll figure it out once we get in there.
Uh,
needless to say,
they did not go through with the surgery,
but that started him out on a lifelong journey of treating and learning about
and treating injuries.
And he went on to get a phd in sports medicine when I was 13 years old.
I loved playing soccer.
It was a super intense soccer player and I got a really serious low back injury
and also ankle injuries and neck injury.
And that was the genesis of my fascination with this work.
And so I began getting interested in exercise and then nutrition.
And when I was 19 I asked my dad what was that injury stuff that he did?
And I was just hooked once I got in.
And I've spent the last 10 years of my life completely focused on learning about
how to deal with injuries and pain.
And I've learned,
I had the opportunity to really learn through the old world schooling of
apprenticeship through my father and through some other amazing people in my
field.
And that's really allowed me to move,
you know,
so far through getting this,
these amazing opportunities for apprenticeship.
So who here has had some injury or pain in the last year?
Wow,
okay.
I think that's just about everyone.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So first of all,
let's define some terms.
So what's an injury?
An injury.
I had defined it very simply as damaged tissue that's causing pain.
So let's talk a little bit about that.
So what gets injured?
Well,
there's lots of different things that get injured and we're going to focus today
mostly on ligaments,
tendons,
and muscles,
a little bit on joints.
And so just to define those terms,
ligaments are,
it's very strong fibers,
tissue that holds your bones together.
So you've got them in your ankles,
you've got them,
a lots of them in your low back,
all the way up your spine and your neck,
anywhere where two bones meet.
So if you go out and reach around to your back and just sort of strum along any
of these spa,
these spines that these are called spinus processes,
then you'll be able to sort of pluck across and field,
those are ligaments that you've got them all over your body.
And if you bend your elbow and you sort of pluck,
there's going to be a,
a,
a sort of stringy fiber there.
That's your bicep tendon,
right?
So tendons hold muscles to bones,
but you've also got one behind your knee,
right?
If you pull your heel,
turn your body,
you can feel them stick out.
So tendons and ligaments tend to sustain injury for a lot longer than muscles
because they have less blood flow to them.
So that's,
that's,
those are the different types of structures that we'll talk about that get
injuries and they cause a lot of different pain and problems.
So let's,
let's call this a ligament or a tendon.
So there's a couple of qualities about this that I want you to keep in mind.
Really important.
So first is their longitudinal,
right?
So these are actually lollipop sticks,
but there's,
and there's about a hundred of them.
So all these fibers are longitudinal that makes them,
it's very important because it makes them extremely powerful when we do have a
demand on them,
it's very,
very strong.
Second Quality I want you to keep in mind is,
is mobile,
right?
They move against each other.
So we're not weird dynamic human beings.
We move in lots of different ways and so that demand is going to change and
shift the demand on the ligament or the tendon.
So,
and let's,
we're going to say that this is so in any given ligament or tendon,
and it could have,
let's say a million fibers,
right?
So let's say you get an injury.
What's an injury?
Damage.
Tissue,
right?
Damage tissue that causes pain.
So you get an injury.
Some of the fibers get torn.
Now in this case,
in most cases it's just a few hundred or maybe a thousand fibers out of a
million.
It's not,
we're not talking torn in half,
right?
Injuries happen all the time.
In fact,
there's normal and natural and also heal all the time.
So let's talk about what happens when it doesn't feel so great.
So you get that terror and the body seeks to be connected to itself always.
So there's a brick as just like if any of you were like,
oh my God,
I broken,
my access to the Internet is like broken.
I like someone,
please pass this up.
Someone please fix this.
The body does the same thing.
So it sends,
it,
sends the immune system and in the immune system goes in and it lays down
something called scar tissue.
Now,
you may have heard different names for this.
Um,
scar tissue adhesions,
adhesive scar tissue,
there's a lot of different names for it and scar tissue goes down and it seeks
to patch it up.
Now it's a lot.
So lizards,
right?
They like grow back tales were much more like the duck tape and glue system.
Like we're much more like as good enough.
Uh,
and so scar tissue is much more like glue.
It's very sticky.
And if you look at it microscopically,
it actually looks like spiderwebs.
And so if you get a tear,
small tear,
micro tear,
all of a sudden those little spider webs get laid down,
thousands of them.
So what's happened to our two qualities that we,
that I spoke about earlier,
they've been compromised,
right?
So all of a sudden they're not all longitudinal.
They're going every which way.
And now that whole area is stuck together.
So now we're,
we're set up to be in a cycle of chronic pain.
So with soft tissue injuries,
the,
the tendency is you get a little bit better and then a little bit worse and then
better.
And then worse than than much worse.
And then a little bit better than a lot better.
And then worse,
that's the cycle of the soft tissue injuries,
right?
So what's happening is you lay down the scar tissue,
then you do a little bit too much.
It breaks again,
more scar tissue goes down,
more pain than it starts to get a little bit better.
Then you tear it again and you're in that chronic cycle.
So
what do you do about that?
Now there's a lot of different ways to address scar tissue.
What are the ways that I use is I go in and then you have to be able to find it.
Um,
but I go in and use manual techniques to simply go ahead and break up that scar
tissue.
So going in and introducing manual movement to break up that scar tissue.
I also use a machine.
There's some people use special tools or other machines.
There's lots of ways.
And however,
two minutes after someone walks out the door of my office,
that scar tissue is going to lay down again.
It's going to start laying down,
but it's new scar tissue.
And we have a new opportunity,
right?
So scar tissue actually remodels,
It learns.
So if just as,
if you were to have a bonsai tree and you wanted to mold that bonsai tree into a
specific shape,
what would you do?
You wouldn't just push on at one time.
No.
Would you sort of tap it whenever you thought about it?
Now you'd build a structure,
right?
You to build a structure to show it the shape that you wanted it to grow in.
So exercise movement is needed for ligaments,
tendons and muscles.
Movement is hugely important to teach that new scar tissue that's laying down
how you want it to form.
So most recent studies say that scar tissue can remodel for up to nine months.
Now it happens more intensively for quite a few weeks directly after an injury.
So,
um,
have with rehabilitative movement,
we want it to be specific,
targeted and measurable.
So if you go in and you do way too much,
you're going to get more tearing.
If you do way too little,
it's not going to get the information that it needs,
right?
So the language of the body is movement,
specifically tension and lack of tension.
So if you don't,
if you're having too much tension,
you're going to have returning.
If you don't have enough,
it's not getting the information that needs.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
So there's a lot of,
oh yeah.
And so over time it's going to regrow and his gain back then integrity.
Now there's a lot of things that tend to cause a lot of confusion around
identifying causes of pain.
So let's talk a little bit about that.
So there's the direct cause of pain,
which we've talked about,
which is going to mean damaged tissue,
inflammation,
swelling.
All those problems are over here now.
Then there's the indirect causes and there's infinite number of indirect causes.
We'll talk about a few of them.
So one of them is posture,
right?
So posture is how you're holding yourself,
So if if I,
next time you guys get up and walk around,
you can try this.
If I drop my right ankle and down towards the ground,
all of a sudden I can already feel pressure on the inside of my knee.
And the inside of my ankle on the outside of my hip.
So for me,
if I were to walk like this for five minutes,
I might be pretty uncomfortable for other people.
They walk around this way,
their whole life never had a pain in their life.
So it's depends.
It's really gonna depend on what,
who is doing it,
right?
So it's indirect.
So that posture and movement patterns,
right?
So again,
Rsi.
So if I take two of you and put you on the computer for the same amount of time
each day for a certain period of time,
one of you might get repetitive strain injury and the other might not.
Right?
So it's indirect.
It can contribute to an eventual damage of tissue,
but it's not necessarily going to contribute to it.
Another one is nutrition,
right?
So our bodies are made of materials,
So the quality of materials that we give it to rebuild has an impact on the
integrity of those tissues.
So if you have low quality ingredients,
more likely to get an injury,
it's indirect.
Some people eat terribly,
they don't,
they don't eat in a very healthy way.
Never have,
hardly ever have pain.
Right?
And other people it really well and they have a lot of pain.
So again,
it's indirect.
So that makes sense.
Great.
So there's another thing,
there's another thing that can cause pain.
It's not necessarily an indirect cost,
which is disease.
And so this is why I always,
always,
always send people to go see a doctor.
Now some people would totally find going to seeing a doctor,
other people there since for different reasons they might be resistant.
So I want to make the case for you that if you have something going on,
even if you think it's relatively mundane,
if it's new,
great idea to go get it checked out by a doctor.
Give you a few examples.
So I have a friend who knows someone who got a terrible headache,
went to the er,
um,
got triaged and put in the waiting room and we're sitting in the waiting room
and five hours later he died.
He had a brain hemorrhage.
Um,
another example is if you have pain when you were raising your arm
in your shoulder,
that could be a lot of different things.
It can also be lung cancer can also be lung cancer.
And I'll leave you with one more if you have pain in both of your heels at the
same time.
Now it could be a lot of things.
It could be Achilles tendonitis,
it could be plantar fasciitis,
it's also a symptom of gonorrhea.
So it's always,
always,
always a good idea to go get these things checked out by a doctor because
there's lots of things that you or I would never know about that you can get
cleared by going to a doctor.
So let's talk about another thing that really trips people up and that's
referred pain to referred pain is when you have damaged tissue in one location
and pain and another.
So this,
this happens mostly in the trunk,
right?
So if,
if I have pain in the ligaments of my low back,
so we talked about the ligaments,
right?
They connect bones together.
So you'll see there's lots of bones here in the low back.
And so there's lots of ligaments,
no ligaments here in the low back can send a pain down the whole leg into the
foot or even just partially down into the leg.
You can send it into the outside of the hip,
make you think you have a hip injury.
You can send it into the inner thigh or the Groin area.
So that's a lot of different places.
Another one is the shoulder,
so shoulder and the shoulder you have quite a few different muscles and tendon
attachment.
So the rotator cuff is,
um,
is actually four different tendons attaching on the head of the Humerus,
which is this upper arm bone here.
And um,
it can,
those,
any injuries to any of those tendons can actually send a pain into this part of
the arm here,
which is on the muscle called the deltoid or even all the way down to the wrist
in the shoulder.
It won't refer any farther than the rest.
So as you can imagine,
if you've got a pain into your deltoid here,
a lot of practitioners will go in and mash on the deltoids for a long time
trying to treat the injury.
Now I've treated thousands of people and in my career I've only seen three
deltoid injuries and all three of them were either circus acrobats or acrobatic
dancers who were holding a person on their arm.
The deltoid is a wonderfully efficient,
is a wonderfully efficient muscle.
It hardly ever gets injured.
The rotator cuff muscles,
four of them,
on the other hand,
they're weak,
they're stabilizers.
Often they get over a tax and they get injured pretty easily and it really
confuses people.
So another one,
uh,
that's a really big deal is the neck.
Now injuries to the front on the ligaments on the front of the neck.
So,
and also a lot of people think if I have referred pain,
I have a nervous issue.
That's sometimes true.
But ligaments and tendons can also refer pain.
It's common misconception.
So if I have injuries to the front of my neck here,
that can send a pain to the front of the chest,
which is pretty uncommon actually.
But what's not uncommon is injuries to the ligaments and the lower back portion,
which gives you a pain right in here,
who here has had a pain in between their shoulder blades.
It's a pretty common pain.
And so I see a lot of people going in and getting different kinds of treatments
in between their spine and their shoulder blade.
Right?
And often it helps for an hour or two or maybe even a week,
but then it comes back.
So the reason for that is that they're not actually getting at the actual damage
site.
Right?
So that pain is actually coming from a different location.
So when the pain goes there,
the muscles tighten up and it feels good to get massage or whatever it is,
but it's often,
often,
often going to come back.
Does that make sense?
And the last one is,
uh,
well actually let's go a few more.
So knowing,
being able to find where the damage scar tissue is is hugely important.
Right?
So in the rotator cuff,
you've got four muscles for 10 and attachments.
Now,
um,
people say,
you know,
people come in and sometimes say,
well,
I've have a rotator cuff and tree.
Well,
they probably did it went to someone who doesn't quite know what they have,
right?
Because they might have a rotator cuff injury,
but they might have something different.
And if they do have a rotating harder at cuff injury,
each one of those tendons does a different thing.
Is treated differently,
is rehab differently.
So I'll give you an example.
You've got,
um,
can I borrow you?
So you have a muscle called the superspinatus know it pushes the arm away from
the body like this,
but not very far.
The deltoids takeover about here.
So it runs along the shoulder here and then dives under this bone here,
which is called your acromion and then attaches up onto the humerus,
which is this upper arm bone.
Now it's under the bone.
This is a very commonly,
uh,
injured tendon.
Now if I'm trying to work on her like this,
I'm never going to impact it.
Right?
So having the knowledge of being able to access it is hugely important.
So for this one,
it's right under the bone here.
I'd have to take the bone off to touch it,
but if I rotate her arm and put it behind her,
it rolls to the front and then I can find it and I can pop in it,
which basically means touch
and,
and so and then I'm able to treat it.
Does that make sense?
Thank you.
So
injuries to the neck can do another thing,
which is that they can actually send a pain on the upper portion.
They can send a pain up into the head and that can,
you can have head pain.
And this is another thing that really confuses people is headaches.
So you can have head pain,
but you can also have um,
a neck injury that's referring pet pain into the head.
And then it can trigger a headache or a Migraine,
which is another thing that I do a lot of work with.
All right.
So we've talked about scar tissue,
we've talked about injuries,
we've talked about referred pain,
direct and indirect causes a pain,
we'll take a few minutes to take a few questions.
So I pretty much budget to do physical therapy once a year for like kind of a
rotating cast of injuries
and um,
and so,
um,
one that often comes into play is like I have recurring like bicep tendinitis
and it gets worse sometimes and then ice gets better.
And I've been told that it's just like everything swells up and gets angry in
green.
That's why it doesn't get better.
So can you talk about the interaction between,
um,
angry tendons and um,
swelling and other types of badness that would cause it to stay bad?
Totally.
Yeah.
So again,
when you have a tendon that is,
this actually comes back to some of,
I think someone over here had the question.
Um,
so if,
if you get an injury to the tendon,
then you're going to have,
uh,
you would,
that means is you've got a tear somewhere.
Not,
not huge,
not in half,
but micro tear.
And if you,
let's say you goose,
do some physical therapy,
um,
you can remodel some of that scar tissue,
but if it,
if you don't build the strength back up in the integrity of that structure,
backup to what it was before,
then what's going to happen is if you do a little too,
too much at the wrong angle a little bit later,
that scar tissue is going to tear again.
And when you've got the tearing with WWE,
even in tendons and ligaments,
when you get 10,
you get a little bit of blood that comes out and then you'll get the swelling
and the inflammation.
And depending on,
um,
the state,
we'll talk about this a little bit more later.
The state of your immune system and function,
you're going to have more swelling or more inflammation or less.
But often it's that cycle of this scar tissue not completely returning to its
original integrity.
You can,
you get about 80% integrity with injuries.
We've militating them.
Does that answer your question?
Okay.
Let's take one more question.
How do you diagnose when something is referred?
Pain versus like pain in the locale or injury in the location where the pain is
felt.
So I don't ever diagnose because I don't have a medical degree,
but ISS w with referred pain,
it's pretty,
there's some simple guidelines.
So there are parts of the body that referring parts of the body that doubt.
So the neck,
shoulders,
spine,
sacrum,
she is here.
And hips,
I'll refer pain,
the elbows,
uh,
the wrists,
the hands,
the knees,
the feet,
they don't.
So if someone has a pain here and they're telling me they have a shoulder
injury,
chances are that they have a neck injury.
I work with,
I work with doctors to check all of these things out also.
So I have people go and get properly diagnosed.
Does that make sense?
But as far as referred,
pain goes.
You know,
it's,
I've had people,
I had a circus performer come to meetings and I have this terrible shoulder pain
any,
but I can't figure it out.
Right?
So I was like,
well,
I don't think you have a shoulder pain.
He's like,
no,
I'm sure I have a shoulder pain.
And I was like,
go ahead and turn your neck.
And he's like,
oh,
that hurts my shoulder.
Weirds
so it's not like it's not rocket scientist if you know about it,
it's not that difficult to figure out.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
When you say that only those areas of referral happened,
you mean tendon ligament referral as opposed to nerf referral?
Right.
Okay.
Thank you.
I just want to,
yeah,
if you have,
if you have a nerve this damage at any point,
then that's going to,
you're going to feel that downstream.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's say,
so this will speak more to your question.
Let's say you,
you've had some injuries,
you've gotten some treatment that's not really working,
right?
What's happening?
So
to be super clear,
I don't heal anybody,
right?
The work that I do get things out of the way,
it helps align things.
They don't actually do the healing.
What does the healing in your body is your immune system?
The immune system does the healing.
So if someone's not healing,
then I start taking a look at what are the things that are affecting your main
system.
Now there's five different things that we're going to talk about that you have
control over that effect,
that impact your immune system,
which does the healing right to div varying degrees of success.
So the first thing,
and we touched on earlier,
is nutrition.
If you imagine that your body is a house,
right?
The materials you use to build it in the body is constantly rebuilding itself.
The materials that you use to rebuild it is going to have a huge impact,
right?
So if you're building it out of Balsa Wood,
you're going to have a lot of problems.
If you just bump into the wall,
that wall's going to have a dent in it,
right?
There's some people where all they have to do is,
you know,
they did get injuries all the time.
They don't know how that happens.
So a few things that you can pay attention to.
The question around nutrition is multiple joint inflammation,
right?
The beginnings of arthritis often shows up in the fingers and the toes.
And the wrists,
even the hips.
So that's a like low hanging fruit.
Like there is something going on with the nutrition.
And now there's two components to nutrition.
There's intake and there's absorption,
right?
So there's what you put into your mouth and then there's what your body takes in
into itself.
Does that make sense?
So we'll talk about a few things in nutrition that pertain to injuries.
First one,
guess what?
Your muscles,
tendons,
ligaments,
joints,
guess what they're made out of protein.
So if you are either not taking in enough protein or you're not absorbing enough
protein,
that's going to be a problem.
Your body that can have a much harder time repairing itself,
getting back to full integrity.
And so again,
you're going to have injuries much more likely for them to recur.
Secondly,
sugar.
So sugar is very well documented at this point that sugar has some negative
impacts on your immune system's ability to function.
This goes also for fake sugars.
So I had a housemate who she liked to eat healthy,
but she loved diet soda and she was complaining of some pretty bad arthritic
knee pain.
And I wasn't treating her at all,
but I just mentioned this to her.
I was like,
oh,
well arthritic sugar,
fake sugars especially can really impact your joints.
And so she was like,
all right,
I'm going to like not have diet soda for months.
And she was like,
went for it in two weeks her knee pain was completely gone and it has been for
years.
It hasn't come back.
And neither is the Diet Soda.
So it's,
it's not subtle.
It's not subtle at all.
Diet has a huge impact.
Um,
the,
so if you're having problems with absorption,
there's a few other signs,
right?
So if you're having indigestion,
stomach aches,
heartburn,
bloating,
gas,
chances are there's something going or even bad breath.
These are all indications that you've got something going on with your
absorption of,
of food and your ability to take in nutrients.
And so that's a really good time too,
in this wonderful,
what modern world of medicine you can go and get that checked out.
Now I work with a company that does these very sophisticated blood tests.
The value analysis that allow you to look at are you,
are you intaking protein properly?
Carbohydrates,
fats,
are you digesting those things and be allow you to make adjustments or to take
supplements that can get you back on track.
And things like that can be hugely impactful.
And we'll get to more of why.
Like everyone has bad digestion a little bit later.
So,
um,
number two,
hydration.
So hydration has three components,
water intake,
electrolyte balance and salt intake.
So the general recommendation for water intake is about half your body weight in
ounces,
not half your body,
bodyweight,
half your body weight in ounces.
Now if you are hugely athletic and doing a lot of movement,
that's going to go up.
And if you're intaking coffee or tea,
which are diuretics,
means you urinate free water,
right water that you would have otherwise absorbed.
And so that ups the intake that you would need daily of water.
So electrolytes a little bit more complicated.
So your body is a battery,
right?
Body has an electrical charge to it.
Now you have um,
a charge differential right there,
positive and negative charge that um,
that drives the of the,
uh,
processes have a lot of cellular processes within your body.
So there's inside yourselves is called the intracellular matrix and outside
yourselves is called the extra extra cellular matrix.
So having a powered,
uh,
negative positive charge differential between them,
hugely important for nutrition delivery,
waste removal as Moses,
all kinds of hugely important things.
If your body battery is low,
your ability for your body to function on many,
many,
many levels,
especially healing,
it's going to be compromised.
And I,
I keep,
I bring medical grade electrolytes with me always.
And um,
so it's,
it's something that has a really big impact and can really improve your health
through having a really healthy electrolyte intake.
Now the last piece is salt.
Now I'm not talking about regular table salt,
right?
So if you've got table salt that is white and crystalline and dry,
that's not the salt I'm talking about.
So best,
all I know about is Celtic Sea salt,
which natural?
It's gray,
it's slightly moist and it has about 85% sodium chloride.
And 15% other minerals.
So electrolytes are mainly about six different salts and minerals in different
balances inside your body.
So it's another thing that you can look to and have control over if you're
having troubles healing from pain or injury.
So the next one is exercise,
right?
So movement,
movement,
like we said,
movement is the language of the body,
right?
It's a use it or lose it.
System.
We were made to move.
These bodies are designed the same way roughly that they were a hundred thousand
years ago.
So whereas rehabilitative exercise we talked about as being specific,
targeted and measurable
Movement for Health is more dynamic,
integrative,
and I would say fun,
right?
The the best exercise that you can do,
the best exercise for you,
period,
is the one that you do.
If you know all kinds of great exercises and you're not doing them in a regular
and consistent way,
they're not doing you any good.
If you like to walk,
walk.
If you like to run,
run,
swim,
rock,
climb,
do circus arts,
like whatever it is,
being able to integrate movement,
movement of any kind.
And if the more varied and dynamic,
the better.
That's hugely important.
So there's six different movements that are essential to all macro human
movement,
right?
So pushing,
pulling,
twisting,
bending,
squatting and lunging,
which is an exaggerated form of running or walking,
right?
So having a mixture of all of those movements in your movement vocabulary,
it's going to be hugely beneficial,
right?
Cause when we talked about how tissues are dynamic,
So that movement,
using that movement keeps that movement at its best.
Lastly,
we'll talk about sleep now when you're asleep,
seven hearing some chuckles.
So when you're,
when you're asleep,
your body does a large portion of the physical healing.
It's like throughout that 24 hour cycle of a day,
a lot of your healing,
physical healing is happening when you're asleep.
Now there's lots of,
you know,
different studies about sleep and you know,
I think the general consensus is 77 to eight hours.
Now there's another way of looking at this.
Who here regularly wakes up and feels rested?
Okay,
a few of you but not many.
So this may be an indication that you're not.
There's two co at the end.
There's two components here to sleep.
There's quality and quantity,
right?
So some people need eight hours,
some people need five.
But the general marker is when you wake up,
you aren't like ready to go.
Right?
So sweet.
And so again,
if you're not,
if you're not sleeping perfectly or not going to die,
you're not going to fall apart.
But it's one of the things to look at,
right?
And if you have like two or more of these things really out of whack,
I wouldn't,
I'm not,
I'm not surprised when I see someone who's got quite a few injuries.
So,
uh,
that's sleep.
Sleep is really important.
Now there's another system that interfaces with your immune system and that's
your nervous system,
right?
So again,
our,
this body is the same.
It was a hundred thousand years ago and we're wired for a different life,
right?
So back then,
stress looked like there's a tiger and my system goes into,
if you guys know about the autonomic nervous system,
you've got fight or flight and restaurant giant.
Just so I see a tiger,
I go into fight or flight,
right?
So I'm either going to fight until one of us has gone or I'm going to run like
hell.
And then so let's say fight it and I killed the tiger,
then I get to relax,
rest maybe eat right?
And,
and the system comes down.
Now when,
when I go into that fight or flight state survival of my,
like it goes to number one.
So what that means is by blood and energy of my body goes to the big moving
muscles of my body and to my brain,
specifically the ones concerned with sight,
smell,
sound,
touch,
right?
And guess what gets turned down?
Immune system.
Digestion,
right?
They go down in their function,
It doesn't matter how well I'm digesting something if I'm getting mauled by a
tiger.
So,
so we live in a world of paper tigers,
right?
It's not so cut and dry,
you know,
the things that,
um,
threatened our existence,
our safety,
they're different.
It's,
it's bills,
it's debt,
it's,
you know,
bosses,
it's deadlines,
you know,
it's,
it's much more hard to pin down things.
And there's not a clear beginning,
middle and end.
So you know,
for a lot of you who are living in that state of stress,
right?
Your,
your system is ready looking for the threat,
right?
And so you know,
so many people in the world today,
I've meats like most people I meet I would guess have some kind of digestive
thing going on,
right?
Because our,
our system is not putting as much energy as it could to that.
So what helps us with our immune system,
with our nervous system rather well,
one of them is rest,
not sleep but rest downtime,
wait space.
Another time is spending time with people that we love,
people who nourish us and this like allows our system to tune down to rest,
to start relaxing in that allows the energy of the body to concern itself more
with digestion and healing.
So hugely important to,
you know,
spend time with the people that you love to give yourself white space,
schedule it out and defendant,
defendant,
like your most important meaning cause really important.
So if you concern yourself with all of those things,
this is not going to just mean less injury and pain.
It's also in most cases going to mean longer life,
more clarity of your mind.
Right?
So there's um,
you know,
it's in service of being out of pain,
but it's also in service of living a really good life.
So thank you.
So let's take,
let's take some questions.
What of these factors,
which ones are,
or I guess what are some practical tips for developing children?
So it seems like with many developmental things,
there's certain critical windows where you really want to get certain things,
right?
So what if you were talking to parents or to teachers,
what are the most important things to focus on in childhood so that you're less
injury prone as an adult?
So the number one to me would be nutrition,
right?
So when I was a kid I didn't eat very well and I pushed my body really hard.
And by the time I was 13,
I bought,
he was a wreck.
Now I was in rough streets for like six years before I started getting really
regular treatment.
And changing my,
how I eat.
So,
and especially,
you know,
you're as a child,
you're building the foundation for the rest of your life.
So the food that you're putting in is actually turning it on off.
I've just different genes and epigenetics that are going to sort of set the
stage for you moving forward.
Oh,
I was wondering if you can,
what inflammation
is and why does like Ibuprofen help heal it?
So,
okay.
Yes.
Inflammation is,
um,
a swelling.
So it means that there's fluid,
right?
There's fluid that's sort of protecting things that gets happens in the body.
So,
um,
we can talk about it in the case of joints,
right?
So if you have an injury to two or more tendons in the shoulder or one or more
ligaments in the knee,
um,
that joint is going to as a protect or even if you're just having an impact and
then you can have an arthritis.
Arthritis just means inflammation of the joint,
right?
So,
and inflammation essentially swelling,
heat and those,
those two components.
So when you have that,
um,
that,
it's,
so you're have usually like in the knee,
you'll have like a teaspoon's amount of fluid and when you get it inflamed,
you can have several tablespoons worth of fluid.
So you're going to have swelling and it's going to have pain,
limited mobility.
And so,
um,
that is going to have,
you know,
again,
it's going to start changing your gait and your posture.
Um,
and then there's,
there's a lot of different ways in,
right?
So I don't know specifically,
um,
about like systemic drugs like Ibuprofen and how that works chemically,
but I can talk to,
um,
antiinflammatories.
So the antiinflammatories like if you had an antiinflammatory injection,
so you can imagine that.
Um,
so imagine like the a street of Boston that's really under construction,
right?
So there's holes in the road,
there's piles of gravel and there's a lot of machines and there's a lot of
construction workers.
So that anti-inflammatory comes in is essentially some guy who comes in and
says,
everybody clear out.
And so they take their trucks and all the people and they clear out.
But what's gets left behind is the holes in the politic Raffle,
right?
So the inflammation is one step in the healing process,
The heat.
And that brings that,
it brings the immune system and it starts rebuilding things.
And so when,
um,
in the case of like a mild trauma to a joint or something,
you,
it's in that case,
it's mostly just like machines and trucks in this analogy and you clear those
out and then you don't have much of a problem.
Right.
And it's just get rid of that.
In the case of when you have like a lot of damage to the tissue and then you
clear that out,
you've just sort of got,
you know,
hopefully it's,
it's gone,
but often you've got this damaged tissue that sort of unfinished that's being
left behind.
And so it makes it pretty easy for to get re injured.
And so you hear about these football players who get a bicep tendon injury and
they go and get an antiinflammatory injection and then they injure it again,
right?
Cause they see there's still damaged tissue there and they'll go to a different
doctrine.
Bulic I haven't had one yet.
I need another injection.
And then they'll entertain it again and I'll go to a third one and be like,
And then,
um,
they'll go and they'll do too much and it can actually pop off and roll up into
the shoulder or down,
which is pretty gross.
But,
but so that's,
that's how antiinflammatories work.
Again,
I'm sorry I can't speak specifically to Ibuprofen,
but in general with antiinflammatories,
that's how it,
that's how it works.
Um,
did that answer your question more or less?
Okay.
Uh,
so you spoke a little earlier about when a muscle is injured,
you want to rehabilitate it and work it in the right way.
Can you be more specific about what makes,
uh,
a rehabilitation exercise the right way for that type of injury?
Sure.
So you want to,
so it's specific and targeted,
right?
So that means that you're actually putting tension through that tissue that's
injured,
right.
If I am doing a rehabilitative exercise to get my trap stronger when I have a,
you know,
or my rhomboids.
So true.
These muscles in the back here when I've got,
you know,
one of the rotator cuff injury muscle is injured,
it's not going to do much for me.
Right?
So you want a specific and then you also want it measure it.
So,
um,
I always have people do it with weights rather than bance.
The reason being that it's not,
it's not measurable,
right?
So if I've got a band,
bands are great if you're just like for health,
right?
But if you're trying to rehabilitate an injury,
you want to be able to measure it.
So I start people out at one pound typically and,
and see how that is right.
With a band,
it has a certain amount of strength here at different amount of strength here in
a different amount of strength here and it degrades over time.
So it's gonna,
it's,
it's more difficult to measure.
So it sounds like what you're saying is it's specifically about isolating the
muscle that was injured and making sure that that is what is being activated.
Yes.
And then again,
we're talking about addressing the direct costs.
So there's lots of practitioners who work with indirect causes,
right?
Working with muscle balance and that kind of thing.
It's more in the PT Realm.
Um,
and that's,
that's not what I do like that can help again with the indirect things,
if we get posture and alignment happening,
then off,
sometimes that injury will just stop getting exacerbated and it will heal up.
In other cases,
you actually need to address this specific injury itself and treat it directly.
Otherwise,
you know,
if I like,
terror,
you know,
something pretty badly,
but I get my alignment really good that Terry is still there.
Like I still need to address that.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great.
I just had a brief followup question about nutrition.
Um,
lots of people have all sorts of health advice.
so this means a lot of things to different people.
So I'm curious if you could just very briefly talk about what you mean.
Why are like the key things that you're saying?
Like say I sugars whenever,
but key things you mean by good nutrition?
So,
right.
Um,
that's one thing I did leave out a little bit.
So when I,
we could have a big debate right about like nutrition and what's the right food
to eat and what's the wrong food to eat.
And basically there's some data on pretty much any food being bad.
So I don't want to get into that discussion.
But what I will say is that if you're eating organic food,
and I know they have a lot of that available here,
that's much better than inorganic food,
right?
So if you're having,
um,
it means less pesticides and usually it means more micro nutrients,
right?
So a lot of agriculture net today is,
is fertilized with NPK,
right?
So nitrogen,
potassium and phosphorus,
which is not all of the nutrients we need to survive.
And we have less and less nutrients in the soil these days.
So that because of topsoil loss,
it's a whole other conversation.
So that's one piece is like eating organic food.
The other thing is eating at home,
right?
So the basic factors when you eat out in a restaurant,
unless it's explicitly stated otherwise,
restaurants tend to carry lower quality food.
That's just how it is.
And again,
some,
some places have like grass fed meat and organic food and like that's a
different story and that's wonderful when you encounter that.
Um,
and you know,
again,
like 10,
like local,
right?
So as foods that are fresher foods that are,
um,
you know,
and having a balance of fats,
carbohydrates and protein is also really,
really important.
Right?
There's always someone out there like ready to like demonize,
you know,
some aspect of food.
But,
you know,
really on the most basic level having like your body is made up of protein,
carbohydrates and fats.
Like you need those things and in good quantities and in and,
um,
good quality.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I a followup question on the inflammation.
so would,
so I'm going to PT for a number of injuries and a lot of time and they're all
tendon injuries.
Um,
and most of the time they'll,
they'll say,
you know,
ice afterward,
um,
maybe even every day or like every night.
Um,
is that suppressing that,
um,
inflammatory response that would help heal or is that different than like
cortisone injections?
So it's dead.
It's different than cortisone injections.
Cold courage,
really in a kind of a controversy.
Um,
I,
I don't have anything against it.
I often have people use heat or cold after doing their exercises and I really go
with what people,
um,
what people prefer both.
So a cold is Aveo a visa,
a constructor,
and heat is a phase of dilator,
which basically means it makes your,
your blood vessels smaller in the case of ice and bigger in the case of he now
my preference is to them do both.
Right?
So doing a minute and if he'd,
and then 30 seconds of cold and then it made it if he,
because what you create in that scenario is a pump rate,
dilation and then construction and then dilation.
And then construction blood is the bringer of nutrients is to take her away of
waste.
And it's the deliver of the immune system.
So blood flow really good.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
All right.
So this is sort of a,
probably a very basic like embarrassingly lack of body awareness question,
but like how do you tell the difference between injuries and like sort of
regular,
you know,
muscle soreness from having been active all the time and like,
cause I feel like,
you know,
being an active person,
I have a lot of aches and pains all over the place,
but like I never know whether it's like something is broken or whether this is
just normal for having done things or,
yeah.
Got It.
Okay.
So there's a few things you can consider it.
One of them is,
again,
it's totally like,
it's totally normal and natural to feel sore after exercise.
What you're going to find is that most often that has is occurring in the muscle
belly.
So if you feel it in the middle of the muscle,
then it's probably normal soreness.
If you feel it on the tendon,
like right on that stringy bit,
that's usually has a bit less sensation.
Um,
then I'm starting to have a different conversation.
The other thing is consistency.
Is it lasting long?
Wait,
if it only lasts three or four days,
um,
we had a maximum then it was probably muscle soreness or it,
you know,
it's case there are a lot of injuries.
I mean,
injuries happen all the time.
They're totally normal and natural for us to get injured.
But what's awesome,
normally the nationalist Freston heal and most of the time that we get injured,
we heal.
And so if,
if you've got something and two weeks in,
it's the same thing and it's bothering you in the same way,
well,
it's time to,
you know,
it's time to go and get something checked out.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Um,
also it's going to be super tender,
right?
Can you just like touch it?
And if I like exercise and I just sit down in my hamstrings,
like sitting on the chairs and that was,
I'm like,
whoa.
Um,
and the last thing is specific,
um,
specific movement being painful,
right?
If you're like,
I have pain here every time I do this right?
That's really pretty clearly.
Like,
oh,
that did something wrong.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
I've got time for one more question.
I'll try and make it a good one.
Yeah.
Um,
so when I have,
uh,
an injury,
it's sort of in the acute stage where I'm like,
ah,
so I mean he's pop,
like I definitely just pulled something,
would I,
what I'm wondering is I know that,
okay,
so the immediate thing is going to happen is like scar tissue is going to start
forming or you'd be working with that and like making sure that,
you know,
it's not like solidifying and,
and you know,
we're working through it and making sure it's healing well.
But I also feel like,
oh,
maybe I should rest for like a couple of days or a week,
like right after it's happened.
And so do you have any advice on like how long should you be resting and injury
when you know,
what's just happened versus how long could you be jumping right in and like
trying to rehab it?
Totally.
So first thing is if you hear like a pop like that,
like,
especially if it swells up within five minutes,
doctor,
like you want to go to a doctor and make sure it's not torn in half are hanging
on by a thread,
excuse me.
Um,
that means that you would want it to get like,
repaired repairative surgery pretty quick.
Most of the time that's not what's happening,
right.
In that case it's,
it's good to go see someone fairly quickly.
Um,
again,
if you have like huge swelling,
take some time,
go to a doctor.
Um,
and then what was the other part of your question?
Like how long to wait?
Yeah,
like I,
I'm not,
I'm not clear on how long I shouldn't,
you know,
ref like rest,
ice,
compression,
elevation,
like at versus how long should I start?
Like,
when should I start stretching and rolling and,
you know,
maybe trying to,
work the muscle.
So if you have an injury like that,
you wouldn't,
I,
you could wait,
you know,
at by about a week,
but you wouldn't want to do anything that hurts,
right?
If you're like,
oh,
I gotta stretch it.
Like you know,
I'm really go in and you wouldn't want to do that.
Right.
So you would want to do something for a gentle,
um,
but I would wait at the maximum of a week if you're really clear like,
oh,
I've entered myself.
Like go see someone if you're not sure and something sticks around for two
weeks,
go see someone to answer your question.
Great.
I think we have time for one more if I've got it.
Yeah.
I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about um,
nerve pain and like nerve inflammation and like,
yeah.
Or feeling process.
Sure.
So nerves is not,
not necessarily my wheelhouse,
but there's certain hallmarks of a nerve pain.
So typically you're going to have three out of these,
two or three out of these symptoms I'm about to list.
So we would probably have constant pain,
right?
Hip pain all the time.
Numbness or tingling all the time.
A change in reflexes,
right.
One side of change and reflects if it happened only on one side,
you're going to have extreme weakness.
Right.
And you're going to have,
um,
but the weakness is going to be asymmetrical,
right?
If someone's really weak over here and they're really weak over here,
they're probably just really weak.
And it's going to be one sided,
typically,
if it's in the case of a disk.
And so if you have two or more of those,
like,
chances are that you've got that you've got a nerf thing and you always want to
go and,
you know,
get imaging and get those things confirmed with the doctor.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
And then as far as,
you know,
healing nerve pain,
I've heard that it's,
it's something like if you've had a damaged nerve that it,
he'll sit about an inch a month.
I can.
This is,
that's not my wheelhouse,
but that's about the rate.
Again,
not if it's totally severed.
You know,
that's a different story.
All right.
[inaudible].